[Applaudissements]
avec redémarre à l'émission avec sacha
le basque à du très lourd avec tiéné et
luigi aussi est ce que tu peux ne pas
nous faire un petit à petit cadeau ce
soir ils me fassent un petit medley de
trois titres que j'ai choisi carabine
avait bien dernier métro ouais c'est des
titres du dernier album et yala il
paraît que tu pense à moi tu m'as dit
quand tu ne chantes c'est conquistadors
conquistadors on a besoin de ces volumes
là d'une benji pour quelle raison ce que
vous pensez à c y et le campus nantais
cette journée ça m'arrive d'être un
studio et si la chanson elle assez
festive qu'elle est qu'elles donnent de
la joie mais je pense à toi à moi oui
mais line % qui pensent à vous ça vous
alors par contre beit-el balemagna la
compagnie créole qui pense au public
avec le bal masqué tu te reconnais
grande écoute le cliff qui ne fait que
du bourg des comptes au mondial et kenji
nichons ce tuto maintenant lui dans
studio il a peut-être lure d'albums
vendus est chiante conquistadors ils
pensent à moi sur mes frères c'est comme
si moi ouais mais pensez à nos pensées
nous c'est une grande amitié
moi je pense tout le temps à vous et
voilà je suis de passage ville basse
mais qui dit c'est que ça me touche de
fou à berne c'est vrai non mais c'est
vrai ça me fait plaisir
alors est ce que tu peux nous faire un
petit medley bien sûr tu préfères que tu
penses avoir plus quand tu chantes
conquistadors que quand une chanteuse
qu'elle m'a aimé savoir un petit peu
j'étais un peu gêné à la commande effet
outre les raisons que vous connaissez
bien sûr bien entendu kenji comme on
avec la guitare je vais pas casser à la
mémoire
tu as choisi je le sens très bien je
sais pas pourquoi vous lui c'est là
qu'est la première et belle comme tu
veux frères fils cadet
[Musique]
l'entente
alors
c'est la vie et peur rien n'est plus
fort que nous
[Musique]
la raison
monsieur
et encore tant qu'humain
là
[Musique]
mon avis
m
[Applaudissements]
mais le dernier métro qui en duo avec
gims un nombre à ce maître gims a alors
si tu veux chez on a à peu près la même
poids je ne cache pas que c'est vraiment
les gens s'y méprenne 1d x etc gims
hanouna c'est bon c'est bonnet blanc
blanc bonnet on fait quoi que tu veux
mon chéri c'est chez toi j'ai perdu et
mon pays
[Musique]
enrico j'ai bien compris le poids des
mots à chacun s'en va
je ne regarderai plus derrière moi s'il
le faut je roulerai sans métro
mais le temps tout est passé avec le
temps doux 120
j'aimerais te parler de ces choses qui
s'en vont et ne reviennent pas
décidément c'est pas si facile j'ai dû
mettre de côté mon nez
tous horizons et commerciaux
mais trop essayer d'avancer pas si
facile
[Musique]
la la
là bas
à
[Musique]
j'adore salaires
c'est la folie déjà habib sy c'est déjà
un tube celle là c'est un tube et bien
sûr ma chanson cette chanson cette
chanson qu'elle a écrite pour moi kenji
conquistadors non seulement des jeunes
en demandait pas tant merci kenji avoir
pensé à moi quand tu es tu écris ces
quelques mots j'étais seul à chanter
j'aime retourner sur juste en nombre des
paroles qui vont me pénétrer
allez c'est parti
oui je ne joue pas en cristal
il est vrai déjà quand je t'adore tu vas
pas aimer mire
quand je joue c'est pour l'homme mais
quand tu bull sans lâcher mon
sur ta bouche j'imagine des histoires si
tu voudras
vais pas ce soir quand je joue jamais au
hasard
ça a commencé comme ça mais jamais fini
tu sais quand ses bas
le feu s'éteint pas comme ça on va pas
mentir on le sait déjà
moi j'oublie tout temps tu danses
c'est comme une évidence
j'ai pleuré
un patient
ilike
leïla
danseur
ces communes
ce
j'ai la patience
allez on y va
là il a une
je pense à toi c'était son petit dernier
que j'ai entendu c'est pou r oui vous ne
rêvez pas ouais surtout quand tu nous as
tu entendu comme moi moi j'oublie tout
quand tu entends ça va
les
tous ces détritus devait l'assortir
qu'en 2021 violent du spot us pour ceux
qui l'ont vu passer d'un bon transit des
scélérats
[Applaudissements]